hello everyone and welcome to pi data
global 2021 my name is camila and i'm
going to be your moderator for this
session now ashraf is going ibrahim
going to talk to us about redefine
insurance with predictive
and preventive artificial intelligence
ashraf holds a master in computer
science and a phd in mathematics both
from texas a.m university and college
station texas
and he worked as a researcher in the
aerospace engineering department
at x am in a nasa funded project
currently uh he is a staff data science
at mozin in riyadh
and his interests include machine
learning finance blockchain and
cryptography
welcome uh hello everybody
so um the agenda of this talk is
a brief introduction to insurance and
i'll be talking about
ai and related technology
and then i will discuss uh four use
cases uh usage-based insurance
and then
claim handling
and insurance price pricing and finally
i'll conclude with
a discussion of
a fraud detection insurance fraud
detection
so
um
so we all know what insurance is
officially like formally we can say it
is a is a contractual agreement between
uh an insurer and uh
our insurer insurer insurance provider
and uh insured
um and the insured uh
in this case will be a policyholder okay
so the insurer is obligated to
compensate the policyholder for some
unpredictable
uh
financial loss within a specific period
of time
okay
so a policy is this kind of agreement
and
a premium is actually what we
pay
um like a monthly payment that just
agree that's the part of the contract
and the claim is in case of uh
this loss um we are as
insurance uh as ensured um
uh we apply for claims
and then sometimes there are the
detectables which is basically um some
amount of um
compensation that um
the insur they insured
pays uh
uh
usually a minimum minimum amount
so
insurance
is divided into
two main
categories and life insurance
and then we have more general insurance
called property and
casualty insurance
and
property this is more of
house insurance or like home insurance
car insurance or auto insurance
this is this is what we we call it
uh property or and and casualty
insurance and the focus here is somewhat
uh
leaning towards uh
the auto insurance so the use cases will
be more more around that but many of the
ideas are actually
applicable to
other type of insurance
so
to talk about artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence is an all
discipline of computer science it is an
as old as
uh
the theory of computability itself
so it started from the
um late 40s and 50s
and even
alan turing the father of
computer science
has
a testicle
turing test
for
assessing
um a machine intelligence
okay so so the word intelligence itself
is a little bit broad in that sense
so
um
machine learning is um
a soft field of
difficulty
legends
where
um
the programmers that explicitly
programmed the model
um
so what happens is um
the model uh once it's been uh
constructed it leans from the data
and basically
it may
contain
parameters that maybe
needs to
optimize
some way
so but what actually pushed artificial
intelligence overall
uh to higher level uh recently and the
booming of
artificial intelligence is primarily due
to the advancement of deep learning so
deep blending is primarily
a neural network that has different
architecture
and different
comes with different architecture and
comes with different algorithms as well
and
the main driving force
behind
neural networks and deep learning um
success is the abundance of data so
we'll be able to get a lot of data
recently
and beside that the computational power
and the increase in
you know
cloud computing
things like
gpus
and all these computational capabilities
that actually help
pushing pushing the deep learning um
and
become more and more
successful successful field solving very
important problems in natural language
processing and computer vision robotics
and
self-driving cars
so it's a very very very
important progress being made recently
okay so insurance companies uh our
insurance industry also try to benefit
from
this boom
artificial intelligence people are using
the data to make better decisions um
uh to improve performance
of business
so this this graph is is just
uh shows the
improvement in in
in uh
uh exp expensure um
uh
on uh artificial intelligence and data
analysis uh
from from last year june and august last
year to made this year
okay
um so uh
so we see that uh data analysis is um
like last year it was around uh
50 percent now it's above above 60
percent
and artificially
intelligence is spending uh is from 40
to almost 60 percent uh in just less
than one year
so this is what what insurance companies
are investing
uh in in
the field of artificial intelligence
and also artificial intelligence
there are many uh
related technologies the big data
analytics
um
uh
we'll talk about uh cloud computing and
talk about um
big data platforms
like pi spark and and and hadoop
and then
[Music]
the cloud computing itself as um
as a new platform of uh pay as you use
um the the
infrastructure okay and that make
a high
computing power more accessible to to um
to small companies and startups which is
also driving the development of of
artificial intelligence
and we can talk also about internet of
things internet of things is
it's a new technology where
the normal
devices
like sensors and cameras
routers can be connected to the internet
okay
uh
or to the cloud uh to the cloud
and um
uh can gather data
um live data
uh so that's a very very important
technology that help in improving uh and
generating a lot of data and improving
the applications
of
artificial intelligence
um
there is also the blockchain which is uh
which is a new technology a relatively
new technology
box of data that's um immune to
uh tampering so to speak
so um this way you can you know save
data insurance the data insurance uh
claims for example
a in a more secure secure manner
okay and
ai and all these technologies can be
used um
to
to improve um how insurance has been
been uh
approached okay one of the use cases i'm
going to talk about is usage based
insurance is more of
an individual based insurance rather
than
categories
okay
so the principle of use usage based
insurance
is to
pay as you
drive or pay as you
uh pay as you and you drive or how you
drive okay
um
uh
so basically if you if you if you are a
good driver a safe driver that that help
you to get
lower lower premiums
and that's definitely encourage safe
driving
okay and for the insurer also
they'll help them to put better price
pricing models so
one of the techniques
um
we're going to discuss later
is how to you know
reduce the price for for good good
good drivers for example in in this case
um uh
and attract attract more of wood drivers
so
um you
increase
you have a better better competitive
edge
in the market
uh
so one of the uh
other
benefits of
of this
use case is
the fraud detection and prevention
okay so um
uh so we have enough data okay gathered
by by the dramatic uh climatics uh so
that we we don't really we can we can
easily detect fraud and
and
misuse of of insurance
okay and then uh also settling claims we
have enough data to make to make to make
the claim settling more more precise
so the data is usually used in this case
is use iot data for example
you can use sensors and gps and cameras
um
even cell phones and and other devices
to gather data about the driving habit
of an individual
and then based on that you can you can
collect this data and
analyze it in a way that
you can
categorize
different type of
drivers of different type of type of
style of driving
okay
so using maybe clustering techniques or
of course i mean when you collect this
data you can build
um maybe
a map a heat map of of the driving um
of the driving and then you can you can
you can
process this data okay using a
techniques
from uh
dimensional reductions like um
uh
svd uh singularity body decompositions
and auto encoders
and and then you can do
also clustering um so there's many ways
of categorize how safe
save the driver
style
the second the second use case is uh
improved
uh claim handling and claim handling is
uh
uh basically is the process of
you know putting the data about the
claim um
processing this data managing this data
and uh
one of the one of the main benefits or
main advantage of that is
basically you can have a better
assessment of the claim so when you have
an accurate accurate uh claim payment
and that's definitely going to reduce
and you can detect early early
signs of fraud and overall this is more
of an effective claim processing so so
um
you can you can take um
the human out of the um or the manual
process of the uh claim claim management
uh and
and try to make it more of an automated
uh
if you use data like the claim nodes
okay this is a
textual data and you need
natural language processing
techniques um
natural language models okay and
what i mean by natural language model is
some sort
and there is many many ways to do that
now the most the most recent one is the
transfer learning
um
and
you can use use also like a simple
simple techniques uh bi-directional lstm
also an option um
so this is basically um doing natural
language processing in and claim notes
you know
and then
use use the output of that
as a way of um processing processing and
managing managing your your claim
okay so um insurance pricing is is it's
a challenging changing problem it's due
to um
the challenge of
assessing the customer risk so if you
uh if you increase your premiums you
lose customers and if you have
low premium you decrease your profit so
so
it's the idea if
how to
uh manage that in a in a
more of uh
intelligent way
okay so people use a lot of data i mean
they claim that the policy information
geographic information even background
data
demographic data and
uh the most the most um
machine learning technique that had been
been used is the three based techniques
like random forest and and and other
boosting uh three based uh
models
okay
um
those have some advantage over the the
classical approach which is general
linear models
um
because in the general linear models uh
usually
there is independence assumption
um and for the of of the variables um
and that's not really necessarily the
case um
uh most of the time
so the three best techniques have some
some sort of uh edge
over over over general linear models
which is a classical classical
techniques that have been used in in
insurance
okay and then finally i will conclude
with um
the insurance fraud detection
so fraud is a big problems insurance and
insurance company around the world
loses a
considerable percentage of their
finances
due to
florida
uh
to
do to fraud fraud claims
uh um so that takes many uh
uh many forms uh one of them is maybe if
if a customer submits forge application
or forge documents or stay an accident
or fabricate some sort of uh accept for
example to to get
the company to pay for for um for uh
the the the vehicle
um
uh
so
uh usually um this data um
uh the for fraud detection is is very
imbalanced data because most of the most
of the claims are legitimate claims not
uh uh
not brought by
um so so this imbalanced data
falls into anomaly detection technique
which is unsupervised
machine learning
so
some some techniques can you can use um
deep learning um
or a support vector machine uh as a like
a one class support vector machine as a
way of uh
detecting anomalies um
and and then
if you have claim nodes you can use
lda
to generate features and then
use deep learning
uh so
uh to detect the the the fraud or
uh
the illegitimate
claims
so that's that the last
use case
this list of references uh discussing
this the same use cases
i briefly talked about
and
i'm happy to take any any questions
thank you so much ashraf for your
presentation we have uh
one question here in the chat what is
the code of from thomas barco what is
the cost of getting the telemetry data
versus the benefit of implementing the
system
okay i'm actually really understand the
question but um
the thematic data
might be costly at the uh
at the moment to implement to use
because we don't have sensors in the car
that produce such such
data
but
in the future
uh there may be um
devices in in the car that um you know
the
the uh
uh
the movement uh the driving style
and also
the gps data as well can be used
um i'm not sure about the second part uh
comparing comparing that to
[Music]
implementation in the in the system
uh i'm not sure i really understand what
that means
okay our time is over uh if you have any
questions and if you would like you have
two options now you can go to the talks
channel and just continue the
conversation and ask your questions
directly through ashraf or you can also
just meet in the other town and have a
conversation ashley thank you so much
for being with us and presenting at pi
data global 2021.
thank you thank you very much and sorry
for not being able to um use my camera
it's no worries at all thank you so much
for being with us all right thank you